we haven't done voicemails in a while I
think it's time okay you know I'm always
a little uh on edge
because I feel I'll be criticized you
always say that and then I never give
you any that are critical so you're
saying there are ones
you just did I'm saying I never give you
any that are critical I was gonna maybe
go on to say there are no critical ones
I don't think you were but it's okay
there's got to be but this is America
where 50 of people hate the other 50
they can't all agree it's a voluntary
thing where people call in and they're
already fans of yours this is not going
to be the place where you there's
craziness in there for sure but good
well that's how you know they're my
people yeah okay let's let's uh I'm
ready I prepared myself okay Eduardo
punch it hey Conan this is state senator
Kathy Breen I'm calling from Maine and
I'm calling to see if you are familiar
with the retired presidential yacht
which is called the USS Sequoia given
that you are such a history buff I
wanted you to know that the ship is
being restored here in Maine at a
shipyard in Belfast and I wanted to
invite you to come and see the ship
sometime during its restoration which
will be over the next few years it's an
amazing vessel literally American
history that will just blow your mind
when you realize all the many events and
historic figures who spent time on the
yacht it was in service from the time of
President Wilson until President Carter
and it really just an amazing Gem of U.S
history and it's your name for a few
years getting restored so I wanted to
invite you to that and find out if
you're familiar with it and see if you
might want to come to Maine and see it
wow that was state senator Kathy Breen I
am aware of the Sequoia I didn't know
about this well I could be wrong but I
think this was the the presidential
yacht that
um is featured in the movie Nixon
remember the movie Nixon that was made
by Oliver Stone with Anthony Hopkins
with Anthony Hopkins as Nixon Nixon used
to love to I think get in the Sequoia if
I'm thinking of the right ship and I
used to like to sail up the Potomac and
that was like his idea of fun which
actually does sound fun but he'd bring
like Haldeman and ehrlichmann and
Kissinger which sounds Less Fun and they
would sit around and go like I think
we're going to get away with it you're
going to get away with it sir uh yeah
yeah boss you're gonna get away with it
I really do hey hey uh let's take it up
to 20 knots what do you say guys and so
I think it was that kind of deal on the
Sequoia but it's portrayed in uh Oliver
Stone's movie they're all
um on the Sequoia and I have to say I've
enjoyed some of Oliver Stone's work but
sometimes he has a heavy touch also and
so if there's one scene in here which
really was like oh that's too much where
Anthony Hopkins as Nixon is on the
Sequoia and they're saying you know Mr
President what should we do about
Cambodia and he's like bomb bomb them
all and then someone says oh but Mr
President there could be loss of life I
don't care bomb bomb bomb and then just
then the chef says Mr President your
steak and he puts a stake in front of
him Nixon just then goes to cut into the
stake and it's all red and juicy and he
goes blood
whoa there's too much blood oh my god
well he then did turn into a bad and
flutter away but you're you know what I
mean I was like come on Oliver Stone I
don't care bomb them all here's some
steak
[Music]
I can't I must go back to my ancestral
Transylvania
but I believe that that is a moment in
film that depicts the president on the
Sequoia well we should get you on that
yacht and you can recreate that scene I
will but you know what we we have to act
quickly because the uh Sequoia is being
restored according to state senator
Cathy Breen Over a four-year period
got no time to waste I would like to see
it though sure too you like that stuff
oh I love every piece of any sort of
History you're like oh I wouldn't say a
plate that you know Reagan used you're
like what a plate
can I hold that yeah I don't I don't
know I think it's a plate especially
that era late Cold War era yes I'm with
you I find that when someone well
usually yeah I mean you have
Eisenhower's phone we talked about this
once and you brought it in and I I
thought that was cool and I'm fascinated
by that stuff so I would love to take a
quick tour of the Sequoia and I think
it's a very nice invitation yeah and
because Sona did you ever have to do
like Duck and Cover drills in school for
nuclear war
but for earthquakes yeah yeah see that's
I think something that shapes a child
that when you have that existential fear
of dying from the Cold War yeah no today
no warning today at my kid's school they
do the same thing doesn't cover but it's
for a nut allergy
oh God I can't even
that was a solid joke
that's how things have changed a little
cheesy
we're having fun hey it's time to Duck
and Cover someone used the wrong pronoun
[Music]
I'm just saying times have changed times
have changed anyway Welcome to our Joe
Rogan moment
I hope you enjoyed it I know
um yeah I would check it out I would
check out a ship well you first of all
you first of all people check out your
mic yeah you just lay down the mic is
seven feet from you I'll check out a
ship yeah well first of all you're not
invited she didn't say Sona she said
Conan that's my implication match she
called the uh podcast she called the
podcast you know what you're right and I
don't often admit I'm wrong but you're
right you never admit you're wrong I
just did I know
um I um
what is with you I don't know it's one
thing you're such a goofball today you
said hand is on your belly I know
because I don't know okay but also can I
say no stay there Sona this is nice I
like the way you are right now I'm very
comfortable right now you know what I
love how entitled are you that you're in
that position and you had your hand on
your bell and you went I check out the
presidential yacht no that's a lot of
entitlement that is so your generation
Millennials how dare you yeah what is
your deal with nut allergies and
pronouns in my generation bruh I think
that's why I think that's why I'm like
this right now you're aging yourself and
I'm getting younger yeah and more
Jamaicans
Millennials yeah okay no I uh the Mills
I'm just saying we
you grew up in a very different world
where okay you had an earthquake drill
but uh we grew up under a constant
existential threat of nuclear war and
that shaped Gourley and I and made us
the the cold Warriors we are today no
walking ball of anxiety because of that
that's not true that's true it's it's
totally true you know what every
generation has their own existential
fears yes no one gets out scot-free we
all are as we always will be and always
have been I'm a wise man who can see
things that others can't see you belong
on a presidential yacht I do I've got to
get on this I got a yacht
of course you will well anyway it's a
very kind uh invitation Kathy and uh I
will try to make this happen because I
would love to see this Sequoia and I
hope I'm right about my um my Nixon
reference I believe that's the ship that
he used to take up and his favorite
thing to do was sail up to Mount Vernon
I read this somewhere I think he used to
like to sail up to Mount Vernon
Washington's home and I think by this
point they were all loaded they were
drinking the whole way and when they got
to Mount Vernon they would fire off a
military salute probably taking the
chimney off of Mount Vernon and then
turn around and come back so those are
good times I wish I had a yacht with a
cannon on it that's what I wish I had
have I mentioned this I was driving
through Missouri I was in a car I was by
myself my car was overheating so I
pulled into the Truman Presidential
Library parking lot and my radiator
overheated and green goo went all over
their parking lot and a docent from The
Truman Library came out and started
yelling at me and I I put my car back
into drive
and and grinding cylinders the whole way
tore out of there straight to the
Eisenhower yeah leaving a bunch of muck
behind steaming muck behind me in a
furious docent so my apologies to the
Truman Presidential Library I don't know
what's your Presidential Library story I
have a car story
you mean you were in a Lincoln oh
huh
I know I um I've been to a I've been to
the Reagan Library I went to the Carter
library with you yeah I met President
Carter yeah that's really nice yeah I
introduced you to not just the president
but uh the first lady Rosalind Carter
was there I started crying you did start
crying yeah and then when we took a
photo he said I could stand next to him
in the photo which was really nice and
it's a great photo it's the four of us
wonderful photo yeah yeah I'm jealous
yeah it was a really nice day I mean
they they like were talking and then his
assistants were like you know you can go
in there if you want after they're done
meeting and I was like I can yeah me
yeah and you know what Carter didn't
have a nut allergy
peace out mic drop